salut c'est hugo après jean-luc
mélenchon marine le pen philippe poutou
ou encore anne hidalgo on continue les
interviews face cachée des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle et aujourd'hui
c'est au tour d'eric zemmour le candidat
du parti reconquête un parti qu'il a
lui-même fondé alors avant de commencer
petite présentation comme à chaque fois
eric zemmour à 63 ans il vient d'une
famille d'origine juive algérienne de
nationalité française c'est à renoncer à
un journaliste qui s'est fait connaître
notamment avec ses livres et sa présence
dans des émissions sur france 2 ou
encore ses news sa première candidature
à l'élection présidentielle
et c'est même d'ailleurs sa première
candidature tout court à une élection il
est considéré comme un candidat
d'extrême droite une qualification que
lui refuse alors dans l'interview face
cachée comme pour les autres candidats
giggs et mauve à faire face à un écran
géant sur lequel défilent des émaux j ai
à plusieurs reprises pendant l'interview
il va appuyer sur le buzzer pour que la
roue s'arrête sur un mémo j la face
cachée de chacun de ces émaux gives a
révélé différents éléments qui seront à
chaque fois le point de départ de
questions de fond concernant son
programme et concernant sa vision de la
france évidemment pensez à vous abonner
à cette chaîne youtube pour ne pas rater
les interviews suivantes ainsi que les
présentations des programmes de tous les
candidats et je vous laisse du coup avec
la vidéo bonjour eric zemmour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté mon
invitation pour les règles du coup son
sont claires pas recommencer l'aller on
va commencer du coup sans plus tarder je
vous invite appuyée sur deux blogueurs
une première fois
[Musique]
la roue
c'est en l'occurrence sur un et mogi
vidéo on va découvrir une vidéo ensemble
et en parler
cette vidéo c'est une vidéo qui a été
filmée en septembre 2021 par le
journaliste rugby zina paris on y voit
des centaines d'étudiants attendre pour
une collecte alimentaire on a beaucoup
parlé sur notre chaîne youtube ou
instagram ces derniers mois de la
détresse économique de nombreux jeunes
de la précarité parfois très importantes
que comptez vous faire pour répondre à
cette urgence de beaucoup de jeunes
c'est vous avez raison c'est
impressionnant c'est sidérant jeu
j'avoue que
si vous voulez je suis d'autant plus
accablé que
j'ai eu évidemment votre âge et que ça
n'existait pas et l'éclat et donc une
dégradation de la jeune de l'es22 la
condition matérielle de la géoéconomie
déjà c'est de quoi vous faire justement
face à ça alors
je pense si vous voulez que
la jeunesse et mal éduqués mal instruite
mal orienté
je pense que
la jeunesse a payé et votre génération à
payer pour toutes nos erreurs pour
toutes nos faiblesses pour toutes nos
lâchetés depuis car le temps hélas que
ce qu'on voit là c'est effectivement une
jeunesse en déshérence matériel je
parlerai du reste plus tard
je pense que ces jeunes gens
soient sont
mal orientés ils sont étudiants et ils
ont des conditions matérielles
insuffisantes soient ils ils ne pas de
travail qui leur permettent de vivre
dans des conditions décentes et donc
dans ses pots situations d'urgence comme
celles qu'on voit ici qui sont des
scènes qu'on peut voir tous les jours
dans nombreuses universités
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quelle mesure est
ce qu'on a le reste pour répondre à sa
survie d'abord pour l'urgence moi je
propose
comment vous dire ce pas de tickets
restaurant ou y est financé en partie
par l'état les universités pour leur
permettre de se nourrir correctement
comme les salariés à bon prix on
pourrait d'ailleurs imaginer que il ne
soit alimentée que par des circuits coup
envoyé d une nourriture correcte pas de
nourriture industrielle quelle
différence avec ce qui fonctionne avec
le crous par exemple aujourd'hui où ce
qu'avait été mise en place par le
gouvernement et c'est à ceux là les
menus sains dans la même la même idée
mais ça c'est pour développer pour
encore plus pour permettre de répondre à
ces situations d'urgence mais sur la
question de l'urgence économique vous
parlez dans une sorte de ticket
restaurant pour les étudiants pour les
jeunes d'ailleurs en quoi il consistera
l'osé que je propose aussi papa tickets
restaurant c'est les tickets restaurants
comme le montant par exemple quelle
différence avec le ce qui fonctionne et
que je ne peux pas vous donner de
détails à ce point je n'établis raza
dans le programme mais ce que je voulais
dire c'est que il faut aussi améliorer
le système de bourse aujourd'hui le
plafond de ressources est trop bas
ce qui fait que et les conditions
d'obtention de la bourse sont trop
laxistes de dire qu'on le donne la
bourse un peu à des gens qui redouble
qui triplent qui ne sont pas assidus
alors à leurs études donc ce que je
voudrais c'est un double mouvement c'est
être plus sévère sur les conditions
d'obtention de la bourse ses parts car
ça va aider des étudiants comme cela
qu'ils en sont mais là on parle
d'étudiants qui perd face sont boursiers
et qui n'ont pas assez de moyens est
d'accord mais justement si on si on
donne plus de bourses à plus de gens ça
va leur permettre d'améliorer leur
ordinaire et permettre à des gens qui
sont de la petite classe moyenne d'à
keddad d'obtenir des bourses est par
ailleurs ce que je vous dis c'est
ceux qui sont pas assidus ce qui
redouble triple ils n'auront plus la
bourse et troisièmement comme dans le
cadre de la grande réforme de
l'éducation nationale que j'appellerais
des en débat par l'aide publique je
pense que les gens seront mieux formés
car ils auront pu s'orienter vers des
métiers verts des situations en
alternance professionnels des 14-15 ans
est ainsi il ne pourrait pas ne
traîneront pas dans une université où
ils le font des études à qui sont des
impasses comme la sociologie et c'est
tout c'est tout c'est tous ces domaines
où nous établirons un numerus clausus
pour qu'il n'y ait pas trop d'étudiants
dans ces secteurs on va passer à la
question suivante nous invite avec
l'appui la notion de eur
et la route s'arrête lentement sur une
carte une carte va donc s'afficher à
l'écran je vous laisse la regarder c'est
donc une carte de l'europe ou de l'union
européenne les deux est ce que vous
savez à quoi correspondent les traits
bleus qu'on voit ici parce que vous avez
une idée de ce à quoi ça pourrait
correspondre je suppose que c'est les
frontières de l'union européenne
exactement ce sont les verts
s'intéressent aux jeux avec que la vraie
fausse frontière entre les deux
irlandais
social à l'est de l'europe effectivement
ce sont les frontières terrestres
extérieur donc de l'union européenne
vous avez déclaré le 9 février 2022 que
vous vouliez je cite un mur à toutes les
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne ce serait pour vous un mur
financé par des fonds européens comme le
réclame d'autres pays européens pour
protéger et là je reprends vos termes la
civilisation européenne
alors quand vous parlez d'un mur à
toutes les frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne de quoi est ce que
vous parlez exactement ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que la
civilisation européenne est aujourd'hui
assailli par d'autres civilisations qui
les envahissent parce qu'ils ont une
démographie plus important par exemple
en particulier au sud vous n'avez pas
mis la frontière mais la frontière la
plus importante c'est la frontière avec
la méditerranée celle de l'italie celles
de l'adresse
celle de la france celle de l'espagne
c'est ça la frontière la plus dangereuse
pour nous et aussi la route par les
balkans parce que sinon ils passent par
les balkans donc nous avons c'est très
simple il faut comprendre savez
l'histoire c'est d'abord de la
démographie les américains disent la
démographie c'est le destin nous avons
400 millions d'habitants la
hausse 1,2 un ancien de votre dessin au
sein de votre carte il y as au sud en
afrique un milliard et demi d'habitants
qui seront 2 milliards en 2050 donc vous
voyez c'est assez simple il y a d'une
part 2 milliards en bas et ce 400
millions aud vous imaginez la suite
c'est à dire la ruée vers l'europe donc
ce qu'il faut c'est nous protéger de
cette rue et si nous ne voulons pas que
la france et l'europe devienne
l'appendice de l'afrique et pour bien
comprendre sur cette question des murs
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'on a dit à
environ 12 pays qui sont favorables à la
conseil national c'est presque la moitié
il faudrait la majorité afin de pouvoir
faire construire ce mur concrètement ce
mur pour bien comprendre en quoi il
consisterait ce qui serait sur toutes
les frontières qui n'a évoqué ici
peut-être en excluant notamment non là
on l'a dit l'irlande en quoi il consiste
sans murs qui est très grand part de
plus de dix mille kilomètres en quoi il
consiste et très concrètement mais
concrètement vous savez tous les pays
qui le réclame ray ferait construire les
murs à leurs frontières pour ça serait
financé par des fonds européens pour une
fois que les fonds européen serait très
utile pour défendre vraiment la
civilisation européenne et les peuples
européens qui se sentent agressés à
sailly envahi submergés et bientôt
remplacer vous savez moi je je je
sillonne la france depuis des mois et
des mois et vous n'imaginez pas le
nombre de gens jeunes vieux hommes
femmes qui me disent sauvez nous ils
nous disent ce qu'ils me disent sauvez
nous de quoi et ça me sourit nous du
grand remplacement sur un autre sujet
donc les métiers liés à la question
d'immigration sur le volet un des
avantages économiques vous proposer de
supprimer ou de restreindre les
prestations sociales rsa aide au
logement etc versés aux étrangers non
européens selon-vous l'économie réalisée
pour est allé jusqu'à 20 milliards
d'euros par an alors là aussi c'est un
chiffre qui est très fortement contesté
certains parlent davantage d'un support
aux alentours de 6 milliards d'euros on
va par revenir sur les questions de des
chiffres là dessus mais très
concrètement davantage sur la
philosophie de cette mesure que répondez
vous à ceux qui estiment qu' il ya une
forme d'injustice à supprimer l'accès
aux prestations sociales à des étrangers
des étrangers qui peuvent contribuer par
leur travail ou par l'impôt sur à ce
même système création alors d'abord il
faut bien comprendre qu'il ya deux types
de prestations sociales il ya les
prestations sociales qui correspondent à
une assurance c'est à dire que je cotise
à travers les a su les charges sociales
pour la retraite pour la santé pour la
sécurité sociale pour la maladie
celle là quand on est malade ou quand on
est retraité on touche là un revenu de
remplacement et une retraite ça ce sont
des cotisations que je n'enlève à
personne ni aux français ni aux
étrangers et puis il y à des prestations
dites les mots tu une importance de
solidarité nationale vous allez dans le
code de la sécurité sociale et vous
verrez ça s'appelle solidarité nationale
nationale la solidarité nationale c'est
à dire que on est solidaire avec la
nation avec les habitants de la nation
les citoyens de la nation
je veux simplement revenir aux principes
originels de cette solidarité nationale
c'est-à-dire qu'elle reste qu elles
redeviennent rationne nationale mais un
étranger qui travaillent en france il
n'est pas il n'a pas la nationalité
française à fulham et en l'occurrence il
est est résident mais en sauce
internationales participent à l'économie
verte à sion je le remercie je pense que
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui en bénéficient
beaucoup plus car pour tout étranger qui
vient en particulier des pays d'afrique
c est une bénédiction que d'être en
france donc j'estime moi que je dois
limiter la solidarité nationale aux
citoyens français au peuple français je
pense par exemple que si vous voulez
c'est absolument scandaleux que les
étrangers clandestins et le droit à une
aide médicale d'état et s'il soutient se
faisait ailleurs on rembourse avant
d'enchaîner si les français et certains
estiment sur cette mesure qui serait
contraire notamment à la constitution
aux principes bien ça entraînerait un
principe de 10 remy nation par la
nationalité oui car notamment sa forme
de chasse toute chose de la constitution
j'assume ce n'est pas contraire à la
constitution chérioux la constitution
qui a été écrite par le général de zain
qui sont celles de la cedr attendez j'ai
compris qu'il était qui a été écrite par
le général de gaulle et par michel debré
ne prévoit rien à ce sujet il ya
simplement un préambule avec la
déclaration des droits de l'homme dont
les juges conseil constitutionnel
conseil d'état cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ont interprété les
principes pour interdire toute
discrimination entre français et
étrangers et ils appellent ça le bloc de
constitutionnalité
c'est cela que vous contestez écoles
absolument je conteste parce que tout
simplement s'il n'y a pas de
discrimination entre les nationaux et
les étrangers
la nation n'a plus de raison d'être
qu'est ce qu'une nation c'est justement
celle qui fait la différence la
distinction est donc la discrimination
entre les français et les étrangers
sinon il ya plus de nation française
comme il ya plus de nation italienne
comme l'appli nation algérienne comme ya
plus une nation iranienne il faut pour
avoir une nation il faut qu'ils aient eu
et nous qu'il y ait les français et les
étrangers et donc effectivement moi je
protège d'abord les français j'estime si
vous voulez que le système social
français est tabou souple 800 plus de
800 milliards de dépenses sociales
chérioux 800 ml maire pareil là dessus
des éléments qui font beaucoup de débats
puisque un rapport de l' ocde que vous
connaissez très sûrement indique que les
immigrés en france rapportent davantage
à l'état français que ce qu'il ne
coûtera les germes rivaux sur rapport on
pourrait en parler tout à fait je les
lui ce rapport est faux je vais vous
dire pourquoi en deux mots ce rapport ne
tient compte que des recettes et des
dépenses immédiates mais il ne tient
absolument pas compte des dépenses pour
l'école des dépenses pour là c'est autre
élément que la sueur évalue à la
surdélinquance des étrangers des
dépenses de prison de 2 des dépenses de
santé pour les clandestins des dép de
toutes les dépenses pour les loger tout
cela d'atrium ans légèrement négative
quand on ajoute les budgets de défense
je peux vous dire moi qu'il est lourde
man négative et de toute façon au delà
des questions d'argent parce que je
pense effectivement que ça nous coûte
une fortune
en plus je ne veux pas que la france
soit ni un pays africain ni un pays
arabo-musulman qui soit le 58e membres
de la oumma la communauté des musulmans
c'est ce qui nous arrivera et c'est ce
qui arrivera à votre génération si je ne
suis pas on mettra des éléments
évidemment à chaque fois on source sur
les différentes études autres qu'on
évoque ici pour que chacun puisse dire
tout ça et on va passer à la question
suivante je voulais s'appuyer sur le
buzzer toujours les meilleurs moments de
l'année liszt
et en l'occurrence c'est pas un
chronomètre c'est un format que font
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle qui passent ici je vais
vous poser un maximum de questions en
une minute l'idée étant de répondre par
oui ou par non mais c'est prendre des
questions on peut répondre par oui ou
par non ce que je suis conscient que ce
soit toujours chaud c'est qu'on est prêt
pour les candidats de l'avoir développé
mais l'idée c'est d'en savoir plus sur
d'autres aspects de vos programmes qu'on
n'aura pas forcément l'occasion
d'évoquer aujourd'hui alors dans la
vidéo de décryptage qu'on fait sur votre
programme on va parler notamment pas mal
d'écologie et de sécurité la france
va-t-elle sortir du nucléaire a surtout
pas faut-il interdire la chasse à courre
selon vous les violences policières
existe-t-elle faut-il bannir les
pesticides
il faut les bannir oui mais je pense que
les agriculteurs sont les plus à même de
les utiliser lesquels bannière emmanuel
macron et tignes le pire président de la
vème république
avec françois hollande ira combat y
aura-t-il une parité femmes hommes dans
votre gouvernement
pas une parité obligatoire
faut-il davantage armée la police
juridiquement oui l'euthanasie doit elle
rester interdites oui est-ce qu'il faut
interdire les voitures dans les grandes
villes note le psg doit-il se séparer du
qatar
c'est pas moi qui décide faut-il
atteindre 100 % de bio dans les cantines
scolaires
n'ont pas spécialement le la discussion
il faut mieux il vaut mieux privilégier
les circuits courts à la religion du bio
une dernière question que j'avais entre
autres la france doit elle rencontré kim
jong-un le dirigeant nord-coréen
la france doit parler à tout le monde
sans tenir compte des régimes on va
passer à la question suivante je suis
conscient que les légumes exercice est
toujours
et la roue va s'arrêter progressivement
au fur cadeaux sur un gars de cette fois
ci mais c'était en fait une question qui
a été posée par un ou une candidate à
l'élection présidentielle qui vous a
posé une question on les écoute et
ensuite je vous laisse y répondre
monsieur zemmour pourquoi tant de haine
dans vos propos et dans votre approche
pourquoi tant de haine je vous laisse
répondre à anne hidalgo j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi tant de bêtises dans sa
question
mais c'est un semblable à bêtises
il ya aucune de haine voilà je ne m
personne absolument personne aujourd'hui
vous savez la gauche bien pensante comme
donc incarne madame hidalgo qui ne
représente plus rien dans le pays il
faut le savoir comme candidat du parti
socialiste cette dame représentent 2%
des intentions de vote c'est à dire rien
et elle continue à pérorer à donner des
leçons de morale à pic la france en
vérité parce que si vous voulez quand
elle me dit que ce retour de haine c'est
à toute la france qu'elle donna sur ce
sujet précisément en 2011 vous a été
condamné pour provocation à la
discrimination raciale en 2018 vous avez
été condamné pour provocation à la haine
envers les musulmans plus récemment
c'est en janvier 2021 vous a été
condamné pour provocation à la haine et
à la violence et injure publique envers
un groupe de personnes en raison de leur
origine peut-on espérer rassembler les
français en tant que président de la
république après plusieurs condamnations
justement pour provocation à la haine
jeune homme il faudrait vous arracher au
discours dominant et il faudrait vous
détacher de la propagande général temps
mais là c'est là c'est une condamnation
le discours de haine n'existe pas je ne
sus jeunes eux et personne c'est une
instrumentalisation
juridico-politique comprenez on veut
ainsi et ça fait des années que ça dure
et pas seulement d'ailleurs pour moi
gagne d'autres personnes qui ont été
ainsi attaqué sous ses fondements
ridicule
on veut discréditer le discours de
défense des français et de la france en
l'affublant de de ridicule injuste y est
injuste
dénonciation de haine il n'y a pas de
discours de haine en tout cas de ma part
je n'ai eu personne simplement je veux
au contraire j'aime les français je
défends les français seulement
aujourd'hui pour la gauche qui a
abandonné le peuple français et la
france et qui ne chérit que les
minorités et les minorités étrangères en
particulier
il considère que défendre la france et
les français est un discours de haine
mais sur mon discours est un discours de
haine 70% des français qui pensent comme
moi regarder tous les sondages et qui
veulent simplement sauver leur pays la
sensibilisation et leur civilisation ont
tous des dix musées à 100 femmes noires
celles qui sont d'accord et discours
libres un discours libres et ses
condamnations dont vous parlez sont en
vérité des condamnations d'un délit
d'opinion vous savez d'autres avant moi
ont été condamnés ainsi prouvé la
console a été condamné ainsi le général
de gaulle a été condamné ainsi donc je
suis sorti c'est sa section natation
pagny c'est qu'on ne les conteste pas je
les conteste pas d'abord je les comptes
et les infantilise large au delà de la
question de ces condamnations d'ailleurs
en justice plus largement ce ressenti
que peut avoir certains français à votre
égard c'est un ressenti qui est partagé
là aussi par un symptôme de français
saoudiens sont d'accord avec vous
d'autres une moins bonne image que vous
êtes vraiment là un sondage opinion way
qui a été réalisé pour les échos que
vous êtes être vue datant de février
2022 ou un certain nombre de français
vous définissent avec des mots qui ne
sont pas forcément des mots qu'on qu'on
estime être liée à la question du
rassemblement voit une posture
présidentielle les modeuses et ne
intolérants racistes etc c'est une image
que beaucoup de français ont de vous
misogyne homophobe etc des termes qui
reviennent dans ce sondage est ce qu'on
peut être capable de rassembler les
français comme doit le faire un présent
dans le public avec ce positionnement la
chirurgie d'abord vous savez beaucoup de
gens sont
complètement déformés par la propagande
dominante et vous-même j'entends dans
vos questions malheureusement même vous
mais après tout vous êtes le relais
cela c'est naturel non mais c'est bien
le pose des questions je comprends que
les condamnations c'est normal de garder
quoi il parle très bien compris et tout
cela sert vous comprenez pourquoi les
associations antiracistes mme attaque en
justice pour pouvoir parce qu'ils savent
que les juges sont d'accord avec eux des
juges de gauche qui ont les mêmes
opinions que et donc ils savent que je
vais être condamné et pourquoi ensuite
ils pourront dire regardez il a été
condamné c'est une instrumentalisation
politique
laissez-moi répondre à mes questions à
vos questions après on passe à la
télévision et on dit regardez il a été
condamné pour discours de haine et
ensuite on dire regardez comme il est
méchant c'est tout ça c'est un système
voyez vous et le résultat c'est que les
malheureusement les gens sont pris parce
qu'ils écoutent des façons district par
ses bons ce bombardement de propagande
mais moi vous savez je crois en
l'intelligence des français cette
campagne va servir à cela l'intelligence
des français va comprendre que en fait
c'est moi qui les défend c'est moi qui
défend le peuple français pour sa
sécurité
pour sa survie c'est moi qui défend la
france qu'il n'y a rien de haineux là
dedans d'ailleurs j'ai dit et répété que
je tendait la main à mes compatriotes
musulmans qui veulent sincèrement aimé
la france et s'approprier l'histoire de
france et s'assimiler à la france il n'y
a aucune haine ni de d'origine ni de
race ni de religion tout cela m'est
étranger simplement moi je défends la
plante et des gens comme madame burgaud
la trahissent tous les jours et et c'est
une autre différence on va passer à la
question suivante je relance du tout la
roue je vous laisse l'arrêté qu'on vous
le souhaitez
c'est une démo j citation il s'agit donc
d'une citation d'une candidate à
l'élection présidentielle qu'on va
découvrir tout de suite cette citation
je vais la lire si vous le souhaitez le
rôle d'un président de la république ce
n'est pas seulement d'être au chevet de
ceux qui n'ont pas besoin qu'on les aide
mais c'est surtout de venir en aide à
ceux qui sont dans une situation de
précarité c'est des mots qui ont été
prononcés par marine le pen lorsque je
l'interview ici même il y a quelques
jours dans ce format dit interview
c'était dans le cadre d'une question où
justement posé question des différences
ou des points communs entre votre
candidature et celle de marine le pen
c'était un élément de sa réponse que
répondez-vous à marine le pen qui
considère que vous ne vous préoccupez
pas assez des personnes les plus
démunies
eh bien écoutez c'est une phrase
intéressante de sa part ça fait
longtemps que je dis que marine le pen
est de gauche et tient un discours de
gauche cette phrase est magnifique elle
aurait pu être tenus par jean luc
mélenchon
moi je me soucie de tous les français je
ne suis pas dans un discours de lutte
des classes du 19e siècle entre les
pauvres et les riches entre les patrons
et les salariés moi je veux rassembler
les français brillent et vous me
reprochez de ne pas rassembler les
français moi je veux justement les rues
ne vous inquiétez pas selon papa je ne
veux pas opposer le bloc populaire et le
bloc élitaire comme le loewe madame le
pen mais moi je veux protéger tous les
français parce que pour que nous
restions en france dans les mesures que
vous proposez donc on s'est plongée
évidemment de votre programme y en a un
certain nombre il ya la baisse de la csg
dont la contribution sociale généralisée
qui n'ont une forme d'impôt que voulait
baisser pour les salaires d'au moins de
2000 euros il ya la mise en place d'une
prime de 10000 euros par naissance dans
les zones rurales on a beaucoup parlé
sur la chaîne en l'occurrence bien c'est
bon de mesures que vous souhaitez la
mettre en place ici j'ai envie de vous
poser aussi une question que se pose à
sa route de personnes qui regardent ces
vidéos la question de votre différence
justement avec marine le pen en termes
de programmes via les points communs qui
sont évidents sur les sujets
d'immigration notamment il ya aussi des
différences entre vos programmes où
situez-vous selon vous les différences
entre marine le pen et votre candidature
sur l'économie et cette phrase parle
d'elle-même
madame le pen est dans une logique de
bloc populaire comme elle dit c'est à
dire elle veut porter la voix comme
jadis le parti communiste d des plus
pauvres des plus modestes elle est en
concurrence avec la france a soumises là
dessus et moi je vous répète je ne veux
pas la lutte des classes moi je gtg une
politique qui doit rassembler le petit
patron et le salarié et c'est pour cela
que vous avez les mesures que vous avez
cités elles ont une philosophie simple
la première c'est le pouvoir d'achat des
français c'est quand l'état vous a
laissé quelque chose or il ya trop de
charges trop d'impôts donc il faut les
baisser le 2é l'adresse de la la csg
dont entre autres en trop entre st apo
de production la baisse de l'iace
lavoyer bon le double familiales etc et
puis la deuxième principe c'est le
salaire net est trop bas pour les routes
pour les salariés mais le salaire brut
chargé pour les patrons avec les charges
sociales et ce trail trouveront donc moi
je trouve des mesures qui augmente le
salaire net vous avez cité la baisse de
la csg vous auriez pu citer aussi le
développement de la participation sans
sans obérer le chat le chili le salaire
brut ou alors ma fameuse prime zéro taxe
vous savez un treizième mois voire la
14e voir un 15e pour ce qui est
d'ailleurs sociale ça c'est un sujet une
distinction d'ailleurs par rapport à
marine mais aussi par madame par rapport
à madame pécresse vous savez on va
enchaîner avec la question suivante
ben on va s'arrêter sur le prochain et
movie là où va ralentir normalement il
s'arrête sur un emoji dur à définir
d'ailleurs une croix interdiction on
voit comme on l'appelle vous avez devant
vous vous allez le voir une liste ou de
12 prénom différent vous les voyez ici
vous avez déclaré en septembre 2021 que
vous vouliez interdire les prénoms noms
français ce une station de votre barre
alors vous avez précisé que les
personnes qui s'appelle déjà avec un
prénom que vous jugez de mon français
n'allait pas changer leur prénom mais
que ça concernerait les futures
naissances après la mise en place d'une
telle mesure concrètement sur cette
liste pour bien comprendre l'idée
générale qu'est ce qui n'est pas un
prénom français selon alain vous avez
dit d'abord à grasse le point
que j'estime nos français c'est pas moi
c'était pendant deux siècles
la règle prenez dans ce qu'on appelait
dans le calendrier donc le calendrier
des saints sont français voilà vous avez
le calendrier tous les jours lassïnce
aussi la saint-michel sa place à ignace
que sais-je la saa martin était donc
là-dessus anclades su vous voyez bien
que il y a issa n'est pas français
mohamed n'est pas français jordan n'est
pas français voyez est d'ailleurs miguel
et giovanni non plus donc si vous voulez
ça ne veut pas dire et kim non plus ça
ne veut pas dire que l'on pourra pas
donner en deuxième ou troisième prénom
des prénoms qui correspondent à ses
grands-parents ses ancêtres etc mais je
considère que c'est un geste vis-à-vis
de la france c'est à dire les parents
quand il donne un prénom nom français
ils disent notre enfant ne vivra pas
dans un univers français dans un univers
culturel français il ne veut pas
s'approprier l'histoire de france qu'est
ce que c'est que les prénoms les prénoms
c'est les héros de l'histoire de france
c'est oui c'est c'est eh voyez c'est
tous ces prénoms là qui ont fait
l'histoire de france et on s'approprie
la culture française millénaire avaient
en donnant des prénoms français on dit
aux français mais enfin vivront avec
vous comme vous et par ailleurs on
protège ses enfants contre toutes les
discriminations on les aide en vérité à
s'insérer à s'intégrer et deux tasses
assimilés dope dans la culture française
et au milieu des français mais sur cette
question de la discrimination si on a
quelqu'un de mon prénom seul vous n'êtes
pas français et qui est victime de
discrimination
est ce que la personne qu'il faut
sanctionner c'est pas plutôt celle qui
est auteur de ces criminels et par moi
je lui tenais à vous voyez c'est une
différence entre vous et moi moi je ne
pense pas je pense que celui qui est
critiquable c'est les parents qui n'ont
pas donner à leurs enfants une chance
d'être mieux acceptée par la société
d'accueil la société d'accueil c'est pas
à la société d'accueil de faire des
efforts c'est à celui qui arrive qui
doit faire des efforts pour s'adapter à
rome fais comme les romains il ce n'est
pas à nous à nous adapter à ceux qui
viennent nous déjà nous les accueillons
nous les logeons nous les nourrissons
nous les mettons à l'école c'est un
effort extraordinaire que nous faisons
il n'y a pas plus généreux que le peuple
français donc j'estime que ce qui arrive
doit pour doivent donner des gestes
voiliers de d'allégeance des gestes de
fraternité avec le peuple français qui
les a accueillis si généreusement on va
passer à la question suivante je relance
la roue je voulais s'arrêter une
nouvelle fois
on va aborder un autre sujet avec un
autre hymne au gie c'est une photo qui
va apparaître derrière c'était mon zizi
je vous laisse là regardez c'est une
photo d'une salle de classe au début du
xxème siècle dans une école française
dans le var si je vous montre cette
photo aujourd'hui c'est pour une raison
le 14 janvier 2022 récemment lors d'un
déplacement dans les hauts de france
avait réclamé le retour d'une école du
passé c'était un terme que vous avez
utilisé c'est d'ailleurs la grande
réforme que de votre quinquennat selon
vous si vous êtes élu président de la
république on a l'occasion d'en parler
au début de cet échange c'est quoi
précisément l'école du passé que vous
souhaitez rétablir basse et l'école de
l'excellence c'est l'école du mérite
c'est l'école du savoir tout ce qu'elle
n'est plus c'est l'école de
l'instruction publique comme on disait
et non pas de l'éducation qui concerne
les parents ses congés le nom j'ai
absolument du ministère de l'instruction
publique comme sous la troisième
république là sur cette photo ça
s'appelait le ministère de l'instruction
publique
c'est l'école qui transmet les savoirs
qui transmet les grands textes
littéraires qui transmet l'histoire de
france qui donne à aimer l'histoire de
france brille et celi le lien avec votre
sujet précédent quand quand on envoie
ses enfants dans cette école là qu'on
vous apprend que les grands héros
français eh ben on donne des prénoms
français a à d de ses héros à ses
enfants parce qu'on veut qu'il leur
ressemble on veut qu'ils poursuivent
nous conviennent moi je viens du sud de
la méditerranée d'où qu'on vienne ils
veulent que pour suivre cette histoire
glorieuse et parce qu'on l'a apprise à
l'école voilà c'est ça la simulation et
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui quand même 40
ans de déstructuration pédagogistes 40
ans de propagande en plus de gauche
multiculturaliste et lgbt ont détruit
les coûts très concrètement en termes de
mesure du coup sûr sur l'école on entend
votre tour votre philosophie en termes
de mesures à mettre en place si vous
êtes président de la république qu'est
ce que ça dire ça veut dire des choses
simples d'abord pour l'école primaire
les fondamentaux lire écrire compter on
mettra pensée mathématique voilà
jusqu'au cou dans l'air sévère comment
supprimer les cours d'anglais me semble
en primaire c'est pas que je supprime
les cours d'anglais de gaieté de coeur
je dis simplement je veux plus de
priorité de voile au français veut plus
d'europe français car les enfants
parlent pas français trop pauvres ils ne
maîtrisent absolument plus l'orthographe
il ne maîtrise même pas les opérations
mathématiques les plus simples il ya eu
un sondage qui prouve que en 1987 70%
des enfants maîtrisait la division ils
ne sont plus que 35 % c'est une
catastrophe et tout est à l'avenant donc
ça c'est oui les méthodes
traditionnelles méthode syllabique pour
apprendre à lire dictée appropriation
des grands textes littéraires parker
récitation parker et calculs mentalement
en la finlande majeur c'est les classes
de niveau aussi attendait avec ça c'est
au collège à la entre les deux a entre
les deux à la fin du cm2 on passe un une
sorte de d'examen mais qui n'est pas un
examen couperet voyez ces ne redouble
pas si on rate l'on voudrait voir
forcément
je redouble pas forcément on à
l'école choisira ceux qui sont vraiment
qui vraiment ont besoin d'une deuxième
année pour rattraper un retard trop
important redoubleront et puis après on
pourra aller on ira en sixième après ce
certificat d'études primaires oui
certificat d'études primaires et on ira
en sixième est là il y aura c'est la fin
du collège unique le collège unique a
été une catastrophe car il a mis dans
des classes hétérogènes avec des enfants
qui n'ont pas le même niveau du cou les
meilleurs ne progressent pas assez juste
pour qu'ils prennent allez vous avec la
tunique c'est le système actuel est
absolument qui existe depuis 30 15 c'est
le collège unique on met des enfants qui
n'ont pas le même niveau dans les mêmes
classes moi je trouve que c'est
catastrophique pour tout le monde pour
les très bons et pour les moins bons et
dernière chose rétablissement des
filières supprimer bêtement par monsieur
lé voilà et surtout surtout un bac qui
redevient sélectif on ne donnera plus le
bac à tout le monde ce qui permettra de
ne plus envoyer tout le monde à
l'université pour qu'il y ait 50 %
d'échec au bout d'un an et voilà et donc
voyez le système scolaire entièrement
rénové mans et vous m'avez dit je finis
de malaz vous malawi c'est l'école du
passé moi j'assume parce que l'école du
passé était meilleur donc beaucoup de
sujets importants et un sujet au passage
qui est passionnant je pense qu'ils
intéressent beaucoup d'entre nous parce
que soit ils sont encore étudiants soit
ils sont dessus mais c'est un sujet qui
est passionnant sur la question vous
avez parlé des classes de niveau sur un
changement majeur par am oration a
évoqué juste ici c'est quelque chose qui
fait débat là aussi certains une étude
qui a été réalisée que vous connaissez
peut-être une étude de marie duru-bellat
et alain mingam qui sont des chercheurs
du cnrs qui ont fait une étude auprès de
vingt mille élèves qui ont conclu sur ce
sujet là de la séparation des élèves les
meilleurs élèves les élèves les moins
bons qu'ils ont conclu que selon leur
étude certes les élèves les plus forts
pâtissent effectivement de la
fréquentation d'une classe d'un niveau
inférieur au leur mais les chercheurs
estiment aussi que les profits qui sont
tirées par les élèves les plus faibles
sont nettement plus importants que les
pertes qui sont subies par les élèves
les plus forts écoutez comment s
qu'ouvrier sujet là très bien depuis 40
ans j'en lis comme ça des études vous
comprenez le biais idéologique est
évident c'est joli c'est oui oui les ces
gens là sont imprégnés de l'idéologie
dominante des pédagogistes et donc ils
cherchent à tout prix à à forcer le
trait
moi ce que je constate c'est qu'en dépit
de toutes ces études le niveau
s'effondre le niveau des plus faibles et
même le niveau des meilleurs nous nous
avions auparavant toutes les médailles
fields c'est à dire le prix nobel de
mathématiques avec les russes
aujourd'hui il ya plus de français
willy à l'ailé le nombre d'enfants qui
font des dictées avec 10 fautes 20
fautes a décuplé
les profs d'université
effaré par le niveau
2 comment dire d'expression de leurs
étudiants qui est d'une faiblesse
insigne et je n'en veux pas assez à ses
enfants évidemment les responsables ce
sont les gens qui font des études comme
ça qu'ils prétendent que c'était mieux
que c'est mieux comme ça et c'est non
c'est une catastrophe donc il faut
revenir à des méthodes sérieuses et
c'est d'ailleurs que c'est encore une
fois des sujets qui sont passionnants et
pour ce qui va le plus d'informations
des études qu'on évoque ici à beaucoup
d'études sur les sujets d'éducation on
mettra de ressources des choses qu'il
faut pour que greg chacun puisse creuser
chacun des six et je suis conscient que
c'est parfois frustrant mais à monza
mais c'est pas grave alors des zones
peuvent creuser on va passer à la
dernière la dernière question une
dernière fois je l'invite à appliquer
sur le buzzer
et sept jours où va s'arrêter cette fois
ci son bras ports français modifier
légèrement parce qu'il circulait sur les
sur cette màj vous allez en fait devoir
reprendre une formule que vous
connaissez sans aucun doute c'est celle
de françois hollande prononcé en 2012
face à nicolas sarkozy le fameux mois
président tous les candidats à la
présidentielle qui viennent ici dans le
cadre de cette interview le font
concrètement vous allez voir on modifie
légèrement la formule l'idée ce que vous
puissiez lire les mots qui s'affiche à
l'écran est complété à chaque fois en
une phrase la trappe président j'imagine
exactement vous allez voir c'est assez à
ses jours dans une fois que ça s'affiche
je vous laisse vous pouvez lire à haute
voix est complété à chaque fois en une
phrase moi président les jeunes
auront une école de meilleure qualité la
suivante mois président mon ennemi sera
les ennemis de la france
ma première visite officielle sera dans
les pays membres du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu etats-unis russie chine en
gluten rambo des
mois président la france restera la
france c'était la dernière dernière
question merci beaucoup et eric zemmour
merci à vous d'avoir pris le temps
d'échanger sur votre programme et sur
votre vision de la france comme on le
fait avec tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle avec qu'il
initie cette vidéo s'accompagne d'une
autre vidéo qui en fait une vidéo de
présentation de votre programme
convainquez du coût sera disponible sur
cette même chaîne youtube que du coup
ceux qui nous regardent vont pouvoir
découvrir j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
vous le dire pour découvrir les
interviews suivante qui vont arriver
dans les prochains jours n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner directement à cette chaîne
youtube on fera aussi d'autres contenus
notamment sur instagram de comparaison
des programmes les candidats sur
différentes thématiques que vous allez
pouvoir découvrir sur notre compte
instagram hugo décrypte et on se dit du
coup a très vite